ciao raga stiamo andando al milan games
week con
allora tra le cose che faremo oggi da
più [ __ ] di giunto secondo me sarà il
labirinto fisiche che ci ho capito che
dovremo cercare di orientarsi cercherò
di registrare bene questa cosa forse ci
sarà anche iacopino intensa san paoli
ringrazio di cuore
tantissimo il fatto che fate buttate per
le robe tipo aver organizzato solo ma
gamesweek gestisce news xfactor tutto
però c'è una roba che va bene quando
eravamo in giappone siamo tornati da
quattro giorni io avevo il mio per me
conto
la mia per picard in questi amante
e quindi casato parecchio nel senso che
il cibo alcuno tornare bene l'app si può
fare con i pc gratis si può provare
gratis la tutti gli sportelli giapponesi
perché possono prelevare tutti i batteri
nel mondo gratuito
questo maledetto non ce l'aveva il per
me condono quindi ogni volta che doveva
prelevare era un casino perché non
riusciva a prelevare eccetera aspetta
non ha finito e quindi tutte le cose che
dovrà comprare lui alla fine gliel'ho
comprato io tanto per cambiare quindi
lui si è evitato fino al collo con me
tanto che ha dovuto fare
lavoretti facendo dei lavoretti per
forzati per poter recuperare tutti i
soldi che io gli ho prestato tavoletti
forzati tipo questo costo di non
ripagare i debiti questi ragazzi questa
è la nostra entrata ai games week solo
per farvi capire in grande stile
allora ragazzi arrivati anche sling
stiamo nello stand sono anche con jacopo
tutti microfonati oggi sei anche tu
microfonato iacopino bene andiamo a fare
il labirinto è cosa molto [ __ ] che
secondo me lui si perde lo lascio letto
io invece me ne vado a casa è contento
jacopo si va in famiglia cameron
diviso tenere fermo
jacopo cameraman ancora riprende bravo
prendi ancora liberi
dovendo
ranieri sta bloccando io
didatta vita piazza è venuto a trovarci
anche all'interno ciao ciao vincere ciao
ciao caro
[Applauso]
di più di massa la buona
e bellissimo di te
[Musica]
beh
no
e fu così che il canestro venne bloccato
la famiglia jacopo grazie a kabul e lo
stende nostro braccianti basta
maria dice enorme che neanche al mar di
garri c'è una ragazza che alla mia
maglietta ii e jacopo gli lancia il
pallone
ma qui
[Musica]
bella maglietta
siamo miracolosamente turati dello stand
c'è un po di gente c'è più gente fuori
di testa
va beh ciao papà papà era avviato adesso
arrivata una rarità arrivano sempre
tardi ecco il passo ma puliva i vetri
tanti antonio ciao antonio è bello
antonio stiamo andando a linea stand di
intesa per perché ma non tono riprovo
lusso nou per giocare un po fesso
con lui perché perché io guardo quasi la
videocamera equa esso o 4 milioni di
iscritti è qui niente stiamo cercando
allo stand di intesa il problema è che
c'è un sacco di gente vediamo se
riusciamo a farci guarda che monica
stiamo giocando con il mega schermo
così le mie figure di kakà le vedono
tutti
poi c'è il commentatore commentato a
rischo metà partita la cosa
[Musica]
beh
non parlasse pazzesco
ma
no
[Musica]
proprio per oggi microfono c e c e c
mascella più stiamo facendo la chiusa e
quindi io cercavo il microfono perché
sono youtuber professionista ragazzi
questo è rapito dai pezzi c'è giovanni
tripodo afghana e in di ragazzi questa è
la vita del games week
mi sono anche tagliato i capelli nel
mentre si come al solito la genesi che
abbiamo trovato un'accoglienza
calorosissima e così come in tutte le
sue ieri una riffa la zio allusione a
300 ragazzi come se mi piace il momento
mi piace anche ai social comitato
descrizione della fit chiede e non ci
vediamo un persona che senti di trucco o
che onore perché voi non chi ha danzato
lavori come questa perché non cliccate
il tasto quando cliccano è vero che
lesione della logi six jona ok se si
guarda si no non sei cliccava ecco
adesso sta funziona perché c'è ci vuole
il mio dito effettivamente ai tuoi anni
il vecchio p
[Musica]